[Music]
[Applause]
the huawei watch gt3 powered by harmony
os is my perfect companion to keep me
fit and active with over 100 workout
modes my watch gt3 is always there to
track all my activities so whatever spot
you're into you'll be able to track it
with this watch and check your workout
data details on your mobile phone you'll
be able to track your workout time
calories burned heart rate curve heart
rate interval data details and more i
need a reliable companion to track my
health all day long hence having a watch
with long battery life is extremely
important with the huawei watch gt3 it
can last up to 7 days with a single
charge so no more issues of my watch
dying midday or halfway through my
workout i mean come on that's so
annoying the best part is i can even
answer phone calls via the watch itself
which is super convenient
hi han hi han where are you at i just
finished my workout i'll be home soon
see you
soon
nowadays we spend many hours working in
front of the computer without taking any
breaks did you know that when you work
long hours without taking any breaks
you'll need more oxygen to fill your
brain however the human body can only
take in limited amount of oxygen as a
result overworking can cause dizziness
fatigue poor memory and even serious
damage to your health
i rely on this to monitor my health all
day long the huawei watch gt3 is based
on the new trusin 5.0 plus heart rate
and spo2 monitoring the 5 system dual
band gnss provides accurate positioning
so by monitoring my blood oxygen health
and stress state in real time this helps
me prioritize my health and take the
appropriate breaks when necessary so
when i know that i'm stressed out i'll
stop what i'm doing close my eyes and
practice deep breathing to reduce my
stress and heart rate this is a really
useful feature for my mental health
i wear this watch to sleep every night
to monitor my sleep patterns
with the huawei ai technology it
accurately identifies 6 typical sleep
problems such as difficulty falling
asleep light sleep easy waking at night
early awakening multiple dreams
irregular work and rest by viewing the
sleep report you can know in detail your
rem sleep light sleep and deep sleep
time ratios and intervals for example if
there is too little deep sleep the night
before you can make adjustments by
avoiding high intensity physical
exercises or reducing your caffeine
intake close to bedtime
having a reliable smartwatch is
extremely important for you to track
your health and provide you with
accurate real-time data the one i'm
wearing is the huawei watch gt3 42mm for
those of you who prefer a bigger watch
face there's also another variant with a
46 mm watch face some of you might be
wondering do i need to be a huawei
mobile phone user to use this watch nope
you can use this watch no matter what
phone user you are whether you're an
iphone user or any other android phones
once you have your huawei watch gt3
simply scan the qr code in the box and
download the huawei health app to
connect
[Music]
you